i think both you and i have been in a
space where we've both been very
irritated by the sort of stodginess of
conservative media by the fact that so
much of conservative media seems stuck
in a rut unwilling to kind of move out
of that right what do you think that rut
is how do we define it how do how do you
break out of it how how do you think
that the conservative movement can move
past its image of stodgy because i mean
you know me i'm about as stodgy human
beings it's possible to be i listen to
classical music i go to synagogue on a
regular basis i go home with my wife and
my teachers that's dodgy synagogue
apparently i mean i mean when we're not
planning world domination it's pretty
stodgy if your last name weren't shapiro
that would sound incredibly anti-semitic
but then
i would just say synagogue is so stodgy
i hate those synagogue attendees well i
mean i don't think you go there for
parties i mean it's like they're raves
going on at the synagogue it's not just
a bunch of glow sticks on a rabbi but by
the same token obviously the
conservative movement has it feels
either stodgy or
provocateurish those are the only two
yeah those are the only two medium in
which people media and which people tend
to work right you've got like the milo
yiannopoulos i'm just gonna say stuff to
say stuff and piss people off yeah and
then you've got the paul ryan let me
wonk you to death right
how does conservatism find a middle
ground that actually appeals to a
broader swath of people well first off i
know that you really hate the sort of
the provocateurship if that's the word
just for the sake of it and i appreciate
that you've delineated between what we
do and people who just go out there and
say something you know racist i
appreciate that because i know listen we
could get in hot water and i know that
you know our heart and where we come
from and our goal is never to actually
just uh to denigrate people or even even
necessarily ideas oh some of them like
bernie sanders that's fine uh but um
yeah you know it's it's
here here's the solution what you're
doing and what i'm doing and i think
this will actually be the closing
segment uh uh on on this week's show
this thursday
we see people all the time say won't
somebody do something i mean how many
rooms did we sit in with these
underground organizations i think the
cats out of the bag with that one we
were like where's the conservative late
night you know where's the answer to the
daily show and i was at fox pitching the
show that i'm doing for day in and day
out for four and a half years and i'm
just saying no it's not gonna work they
paired me up with a guy who who was like
he was like 90 years old with
four-year-old kid like that's old
testament abraham i don't know how it
happens
it was so bizarre and he like had these
ideas like a monkey on roller skates and
what it is is just people this is true i
know it's downgraded but i'm trying to
put that piece together in my time there
people say well why
isn't some why don't we have this isn't
someone going to do something just be
the guy who does something we're doing
the show that we wish we wished had
existed people told me there was no
market for it uh i'm very grateful for
the market that there there is fort and
every time we gain a new subscriber or a
new mug club uh uh member we've raised
the ceiling and we
really are just incredibly grateful i
think there are two ways to handle
success to either become to either exalt
yourself or to feel genuinely humbled by
the responsibility of how much it means
to people and and that's honestly like
when i got off stage at smu uh i
remember walking in the bathroom and
like like crying for a little bit
because for me as a kid stand up that
was kind of a dream come true to have
you know 20 700 people roaring and
cheering like for someone else it didn't
mean a whole lot but for me that was
something that i thought about ever
since i was a kid and you go oh what do
i do from from here you know how do i
hang on to this and this also and some
of these people were crying because you
know they left them they had left islam
and now they couldn't talk with their
parents or giving me their navy cross um
so i it's just be the person who does
something we're doing the show that we
wanted to do and i know that you for a
long time listen you did a lot of am
radio and you you appeared on a lot of
people both slogged and yes in a lot of
in a lot of trenches but you finally
just i know that you're going why
doesn't somebody do something i know
behind closed doors sometimes people who
are more high profile respectfully you
think they're idiots
uh and uh i know that you're like man
i'm ten times smarter than that guy and
i was like yeah you you are but this is
just the way the system works right now
and now you're doing it and now we're
doing it so i just think for people how
does it change it changes with what
we're doing and hopefully more people
out there are doing it um i you know i
don't see many ben shapiro's on the
horizon there are a lot of people who
are young and smart there are there's no
one else out there as far as young
comedians that's what kind of worries me
for me to retire i would love to pass
that torch to somebody there's just it's
going to be ten years before sort of
someone's coming something is holding
31 but i can't i can't do this for that
long oh really okay so how long do you
think you're i i would love i would love
to be able to train someone up you know
within 10 years and have someone else be
doing retired 41. not retire but be able
to you know be able to help the next
young people what's your dream then so
like you just decide not to do this as
often or you do it occasionally again
because i was pitching this show to like
i'm sure you probably pitched books that
got turned down oh you're all all you're
getting published at what seven years
old 19 but yeah okay yeah but you didn't
look a day past 14. so that's you know
that's what really counts but um
i would love to be the person who
said to a young stephen crowder this
will never work
change my mind is not a book that people
want late night comedy is not something
that conservatives want i would love to
be the guy goes okay kid
you're you're talented uh let's see how
hard you work at it and let me you know
be be a wind uh
in your sails here um i'd love to be
able to do that eventually you know it's
it's really not about myself because if
it dies with me then it's all for for
nothing unfortunately there aren't many
conservative uh i don't even say
comedians but entertainers out there you
know because the system kind of like you
said it breeds sort of young um
cnn crossfire era tucker carlson
lookalikes when you go to a lot of these
conventions and that's changing now
that's changing a lot you're seeing a
very
you're seeing a much more diverse uh uh
group of people like when i went to
speak at yaf you're seeing a lot of
alternative people you know people there
with tattoos and mohawks you've seen a
lot of people who are not afraid to at
least ex to at least explore their
options so that's what's important to me
i would really love to see some more
people coming up you know it's they've
got to earn it they've got to earn it i
think this is right i mean there's a
cultivated skill set and i've seen it
even with you because i've known you
long enough i mean i've known you for a
decade so i've seen how even in the time
we've known each other your comedy has
really progressed to the point where i
mean you were always good but now you're
just terrific in a way that you weren't
a long time ago and that is through
cultivation of skill and effort and i
feel the same way about my own career
i've been doing this since i was 17
which means i've been doing this for 17
years now and i feel like i've gotten
better at it because you put in the time
and you get better you've gotten so many
reps in yeah exactly exactly like at a
certain point
you really have to cultivate a skill it
feels like the movement spends an awful
lot of time promoting people who have
not actually spent the time cultivating
the skill yeah if you if you either
mouth the platitudes or alternatively if
you troll and these are these are the
two paths to fame and glory and the
conservative movement which is you say a
bumper sticker or you say something
really trolly just to get attention
right and then you are celebrated by the
people who are glad that somebody said
something offensive right that's not i
think where the future of the movement
lies that's why i'm inspired to see you
do so well uh because there was a period
like you and i both know there was a
period not that long ago where we
thought our careers were in doubt
because it was just the whole kind of
trolley or bumper sticker slogan we both
i remember talking on the phone so we
had many of these conversations like man
i don't know if this is the end of this
where it's a bumper sticker or just
saying something outlandish but that's
not what we do and we're not going to
change who we are so you know you're
success i always i always sort of
vicariously live through your success
room like man i'm glad to see that
someone can do what ben does because
he's doing what he wanted to do for a
long time it is more substantive it is
not what media used to be and guess what
people have been craving it that means a
lot to me one of my one of my favorite
films like we talk about
uh we're talking sort of about
passing the torch you ever see the
shooters was john wayne's last film yep
okay so for people who don't know it's
about you know this guy who wants to
live out his last day i think he has
cancer pancreatic cancer uh was it's a
young uh ron howard um and uh is it
gregory peck and there who's or is it
jimmy stewart no it's jimmy stewart and
who's a woman is it annette i can't
remember i don't know anyway but the
point is he goes uh to this town he's
this famous shootist you know he's a
shootout artist and uh he wants to die
so he wants to live quietly but
unfortunately a young
ron howard lets the word out that this
guy is in town and everyone wants to
take their crack at him and at this
point john wayne has a death wish he
wants to die so at that point he goes
out publicly to the saloon and he can
see all of the guys there who are ready
to shoot him and
it's a very powerful scene for me
because it's the end of the movie the
end of the film and
there's a shootout and at a certain
point actually he shot everybody but
there's i think one guy left with a
shotgun trained on him and he pauses
because he knows he could let this
happen and he wants to die but instead
he turns on and shoots the guy and
finishes his drink and he's kind of
melancholic and it's because
he wanted to be taken out but he wasn't
going to give it to him
and that's kind of how i want there to
be someone else uh eventually but it's
got to be someone who
the same thing i'm sure with you as you
get older when you were tight's gotta be
someone who you can entrust with what
we've built
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content